my father passed away in 2012 he got to
see a glimpse of the
of the i remember like you know he was
an
actor himself he he came from you know
broadway and very thespian and
you know he he was in a star he was in
star trek and he would get fan mail all
the time
um he played like a small role in star
trek three
and he would get these crazy amazing fan
letters and he loved it it was like the
happiest
that he was when he was answering fan
mail for star trek
so when we were out one time uh
because my dad was you know my dad was
going through some stuff but we were out
spending time together and someone came
up to me from
iraq and they're like we watch your show
there and he was just like what the hell
across the world like that that's
amazing
and i was like dude that made me so
happy and it was like a couple months
before he passed away
and he was able to like see the the
reality of
how far reaching this this audience was
that is beautiful and it actually puts a
tear in my eye because i think about
it's just it's just so nice when a
father could be
just love his son so much and want to
see him
be successful and be so
you know just in awe of something like
that
where you know i it just for me
especially just it just
is it's a beautiful thing is he i don't
know it was just
the relationship i could just see it
like when you were just talking about it
i just envisioned it i could see it and
just this
this guy who just cares about you and
was like wow follow from the other side
of the world how does he
how do they recognize you from just and
what that does is that creates this
sort of feeling inside you i'm sure
where it's just like
it just feels good that your dad feels
good about what you're doing and what
you've like
it just that's that's such a fulfilling
feeling
isn't it it is very special and i had a
very close relationship with my parents
um
and my dad you know it's weird it's like
when he passed away
i mean it was so weird because you know
i
the one thing that we would do together
is we'd fish together we'd fly fish
together which is like
in itself another art and a craft that i
still i've been doing it for 31 years
and i still suck at it dude i like to
imagine myself that i'm a master angler
at this point and then i go out on the
on the river and i'm like i can't
i'm what am i doing like why can't i do
this my dad was a master angler
he was he was so good he fished for you
know what 70 years or something
and so we would go and spend time like
that together but after he died like i
still go fishing and i still almost feel
like he's there
it's the weirdest it's so strange
um he is comforting i believe that i
believe he is though
yeah yeah it's a strange thing it's the
one thing that i still can't quite
understand i don't know if it's just my
own imagination and
but well i you know what my best friend
was my grandfather who died
a year and a half ago and he by far he
was
my best friend and uh i mean i i
couldn't stop videotaping him from the
time i was a kid
i just thought he was the funniest
awesomest guy in the world
and he always golfed and i never liked
golf he would take me and i just
never and during this pandemic for the
first time i said [ __ ] well golf's
really the only thing i could do
so i would uh i'd go golf and you can
you know you're with one guy and you're
separated and you're social it's a sport
that you could play you got your own
ball you're touching your own balls that
didn't sound right
but you know for me i always feel like
herbs with me and i feel like there's
some kind of awesome
fee it's just this feeling where i'm
like my grandfather always wanted me to
go
[ __ ] why didn't i golf as much with him
and now
i just feel like there's this there's
this essence like irv here i go
could you help me out apparently not
because i'm sucking up
but there is a nice feeling i don't know
whatever it is it's just
uh like you said spirit you said you're
more spiritual and you know
it's who's to say what's out there
you